She knows I live!
There's a little fishing village in Po-
Better make the shot!
Eh, you're checking her what?
Steal against the wind!
Size any second, quick!
Move to the other side as a counterweight!
Go!
The children took my boat and they almost capsized!
The children!
My son!
He was just sleeping in the boat!
That boy really knows what he's doing, look at him!
Vasco will be a good sailor, he's a natural!
That lad we've just seen proving his seamanship in his native Portuguese village near Lisbon
will very soon go a long way, a very long way.
The end of the 15th century was approaching.
Christopher Columbus, 18 years his senior, would soon set off for America.
Columbus thought he was sailing to the Indies,
but adventurers were already sailing farther across the sea, and some went by land,
like a certain Pedro Coriglia, who was sent by the King of Portugal as an emissary
to spy and travel the so-called spice route: pepper, ginger, cinnamon and cloves, saffron, nutmeg.
At that time, these were very precious and, of course, very expensive.
Expensive. What are you saying? I can go to the supermarket and buy all I want.
Yes, today you can. But back then, it wasn't quite so simple.
We'll see for yourself. The voyage it required at each port of call, duties were levied and merchants' profits paid.
And then when the spices finally arrived in Lisbon...
Hey, merchant, I will have some pepper and nutmeg.
No, but sir, prices have gone up. Transportation is higher, not to mention the taxes.
And now it's taxes on taxes. It means the end of shopkeeping as we know it.
How much?
Well, sir, I'm afraid pepper is worth its weight in pure silver.
That's how it is.
That's sheer madness.
Nevertheless, I need it very well.
Good decision, sir.
A nutmeg is worth half. It's weighed in pure gold.
That's how it is, a luxury product.
Father, it's a fortune.
Yes, we pay too much for spices.
You're right.
Well, we have our own ships. We could get it.
That's impossible, my boy.
We don't know where or how to find such spices.
Some experienced sailors say you'd have to sail all the way around Africa,
but who would dare try it?
They say the sea rushes into a void.
That sea monsters lie and wait for ships.
Why, one of our men has voyaged farthest, Captain Gomez.
And he barely passed the equator.
Oh.
I'm only ten.
Everything will be discovered when I grow up.
Oh, my son, there will be discoveries.
No one has reached the tip of Africa yet.
Or the Indies.
We really know so little.
The pole star vanishes in the south.
Disappears?
Yes.
You've heard of the pole star, Vasco?
Yes, Father.
Pedro told me all about the big and little dippers.
Dippers?
What do you mean?
I'll be very happy to explain about it, Father.
There's the constellation of the great bear.
Some call it the Big Dipper.
You calculate a distance five times as great as the distance between the stars and the handle,
and that's the pole star, indicating north.
And the Little Dipper, the little bear, the pole star, is at the end of the handle.
And do you know why it is the pole star disappears when we approach the equator?
You know why? The Earth's round.
As we go toward the south, it gets lower on the horizon until it disappears.
Young Vasco da Gama will serve as apprentice seaman.
He'll take part on many voyages.
A few years later, his friend, Bartholomew Diaz, will be the first to sail and reach the southern tip of Africa.
The Cape of Storms. Later, it will be called the Cape of Good Hope.
Let's go!
Oh, you reached the Indian Ocean!
Do you realize, Bartholomew, no one's ever gone as far as you did?
I might have gone much farther, but my crew wouldn't go on.
Around Africa, all the way to the Indies.
Who can say that my men were terrified?
Insisted on sailing back, so here I am.
Who's that sailor? Do you know him?
He's a captain from Genoa.
His name is Christopher Columbus.
For some time now, he's tried to convince our king that he can reach the Indies by sailing west.
My sailing west? That's idiocy.
If you can reach the Indies by sailing around Africa, you'll ruin all I planned.
This is just what we need.
Come, my friends, look.
Look at this map. It is highly secret and includes everything known about the world.
My astronomer, Abraham Zakutu Ben Samuel, has brought it up to date,
including information on Pero de Caviglia on the Indies.
It's quite interesting.
The Indies? No one's ever sailed to the Indies.
Caviglia's been all the way to where he made me on a camel.
And the Arabs let him do it?
They converted him into an Arab.
So once I'd sailed around Africa, I was closer to the Indies than I was to Portugal.
Unless I'm wrong, you could have reached the Indies in less than a month.
No, my crew wouldn't go on.
What is this here?
Oh, that's a land discovered by one of my captains.
It's a state secret.
On your oath, you must tell nobody.
Couldn't that be the Indies?
Oh, no, it's a newly discovered land.
We found no gold or spices, but there isn't wood as rather as braised coal, so it's Brazil.
Well then, that captain from Genoa who wants to sail westward to the Indies, what was his name?
Christopher Columbus. He's wrong. To get to the Indies, you have to sail around Africa to the east.
I see why your majesty refuses to finance his expedition. He's--
I have confidence in only you, my Portuguese captains. This Columbus is now selling his services to Spain.
On the 12th of October, 1492, after 36 days at sea, Columbus landed.
He thought he had reached the Indies, but the American continent got in the way.
He discovered it for the Europeans.
You could say he didn't know where he was going, he didn't know where he was when he got there,
and he didn't know where he'd been when he got back.
Ferdinand and Isabella of Spain have an audience with the Pope, Alexander VI.
Your Holiness, it is most important that Spanish and Catholic interests be protected over the Western Oceans.
Permit me to remind you that you are Spanish as well.
Meh.
Write it down.
I would declare that all territories discovered by Christopher Columbus now and henceforth are Spanish.
All other territories discovered west of the Azores will be considered possessions of Spain as well.
Will that do it?
Uh-huh.
Here's your edict.
And a parchment with the papal bull sent to the king of Portugal.
No, I cannot agree with this!
That's it! They want everything, he's Spanish!
I will personally confront Ferdinand and Isabella, but give me the other map, I won't take this one.
It is the Pope's decree, he's quite right. Spain is a large country, it's only right that we take the greater part.
Now Portugal's small with a smaller part, that's all.
We do not agree. I remind you Portugal has a powerful and well-equipped navy. Consider.
What do you suggest?
I suggest a line of demarcation drawn here.
I don't see what you gain.
There's nothing but water. However, if that will please you.
And so you see, through the treaty signed at Tordesales, Portugal acquired Brazil.
The Spanish didn't even know it existed, but the Portuguese did.
Ah...
You've made up my mind, Vasco, you will command the exposition to the Indies.
Paulo de Gama, you will be captain of one of the ships.
And you, Abraham, you will instruct my captains in the mysteries of the stars in the southern hemisphere.
Yes, with your knowledge and experience, you're the best suited to supervise preparations.
You'll navigate by the Southern Cross, Captains.
Manuel, my cousin, you'll soon be king. You must always remember the interests of Portugal lie beyond the seas.
Salted meat, biscuits, rumpel, sardines, prunes, almonds, onions, garlic, and mustard.
Sugar, flour, honey, it's all here.
Sign to the supply ship. I'm gonna give 'em plenty of headaches, all right.
And I'm gonna make sure that they get a big reception in Africa.
Don't worry, the Spanish always pay well, not for you.
The Holy Church grants eternal salvation to all those who boldly venture forth on the seas for the glory of our country.
Starboard!
Close heart of starboard!
If you sail along the coast, your route will be shorter and safer.
But the winds are erratic, and the currents will slow you up.
I won't hug the coast.
I'm going much farther out and due south to take advantage of favorable winds.
A thousand miles out to sea?
Hmm.
Well, it will be dangerous, but you know what you're doing.
May God protect you.
Polestar, also called the North Star.
You will go below the horizon. We're near the equator.
But then, find directions, Captain.
Ha! You'll see, lad.
What is your name?
Miguelito. I want to be a sailor one day.
Here, of course, South, South, West.
Was it South, South, West, Captain?
Oh, well...
You heard me. I want South, South, West.
Harder star!
Get it.
It's Wazzy steering right or left.
Starboard?
Not very simple. Starboard is to the right of a ship.
Starboard is to the right and port to the left of the ship.
Right, but why to starboard to the right, when Africa is on the left to port?
It's a daring decision, but based upon observations of Portuguese sailors who'd sail these waters,
Vasco made for open sea to avoid the counter currents and unfavorable winds that he knew he would find that were nearer to the coast.
Six weeks out on the open sea, the captain's taken us to our doom!
Yes, we oughta go back home!
We could come and do this ship!
Yeah, let's do it!
Hmm, you see, the midday sun's practically below the horizon, we are near the Tropic of Capricorn.
Yeah, right?
Here.
So we sail to port side, close to the east?
That's right, Miguelito!
Relay my order.
Go on.
Me, sir?
Yes.
Haha.
Harder port side, steer due east!
Giving the order!
Those are my orders.
Harder port side, steer due east!
Hi Captain, at your orders!
Meanwhile, on the other side of Africa...
Isn't very fine to Mombasa.
Only three, four weeks.
Who's in hurry hurry?
Hmm.
Not since we've been out to sea and no side of land.
With this Captain, we'll all be lost to-
Now we take the ship!
That thing!
Seaweed!
We must be near land!
Sound the depth.
104, 105, 106, 107, 108, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109, 109,
104, 105, 106, 107, 108, 109, 1010, 9, 7, 6, 7, 8.
Remarkable, truly extraordinary feat. Never done till then.
Three months out in the open sea with no means of navigation except the stars.
And Vasco da Gama stepped ashore almost exactly where it intended.
Not far from the Cape of Good Hope, naturally.
The sailors shouted with joy.
Yay. The last of me.
Stay here a few days to repair our sails and then we'll take on our new provisions.
See to it. Turn to his home. Take you ashore.
Seem friendly and very much like us.
I think that we might get on very well, all of us, don't you think?
No. The Portuguese are very bad. They're bad.
Watch your necklaces, and your bracelet.
You've got our assing eyes, your spears, right?
Oh, I'm good. I'm good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But I am surprised. They seem to be extremely friendly.
Well, too bad. We have our provisions, and so we can be on our way.
We sail south.
There. The exact spot where Bartholomew Diaz turned around ten years ago.
You mean nobody's ever gone any, well, any further?
Not yet.
Supply!
Are you going to come here with a lot of Portuguese sailors?
The moor and many precious things, and gold, I think you understand.
We will go ashore tomorrow morning.
A few days ago, Spaniards show up in Nombasa.
Got some bandits to come attack us.
Goundrels!
Ask him what is the nearest seaport to the north.
While in there, 30 leagues.
We'll sail there.
Canons, the moors don't have any, but, uh, maybe they're East Indians?
Yes, could be East Indian Christians. Make no in our presence.
they are East Indians. Our goal can't be far. Now we need a pilot who knows these waters.
Look at that. They sure know how to put on a show. Quiet. He's surely a king or something.
Go and get Ahmed. He will interpret. It is not Taj Mahal. He welcome you here and invites
us all to festivities he is pleased to be offering in order of a visit. Ask him if you
give me a pilot to go to India. Ah, he hopes you like peanuts and saffron in your curry.
The festivities are being over.
He's soon coming.
Enough of this, come!
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
Sultan is looking for his minister, the little bearded one, you seen him?
You go and tell the Sultan that I will trade his minister for a competent planet.
Sultan sends respects and most experienced pilot in Indian Ocean.
He knows all currents and the reefs and sandbars, you know.
Name Ibn Majid.
Ah, then he can have his minister back.
You will drop him off and return to the ship.
But the festivities aren't over.
They're over and you had a good time.
We set sail in one hour, Paolo.
Take the minister ashore and round up all our men!
Ehhh!
Let's see if this pilot's as good as they say!
What's my route to the Indies?
Ask him, hmm?
Michael Burke, the Info's at the Big Weef.
I suppose he said steer North East.
Go on!
Maybe you forgot something?
Uh, did forget!
Cow--
And Shoals lie straight ahead.
You sail around them, to North.
Now we can see the Polestar again.
We are moving toward the Northern Hemisphere.
Goddard, we better announce our arrival to Zamorin.
Zamorin?
The ruler here, Captain.
A man fond of celebrations.
Oh, another one!
Splendors of such magnificence, all these spices, pepper, nutmeg, ginger, saffron, and all these precious jewels, diamonds, emeralds, rubies.
He wants to know what you're doing here.
I get the picture.
Tell the impotentate that I am sent by King Manuel of Portugal, who sends greetings and wants to establish friendly relations for future consul Portugal.
He says, um, that you're welcome and that he'll send ambassador or something like that.
something like that. Calcutta in India. Two centuries earlier, the Venetian Marco Polo had
been here after crossing the Asian landmass. A century after him, Shanghai, with his great
junks, had called here. And now here's Vasco de Gama, who sailed around Africa to get here,
opening a sea route to the Indies. From then on, the treasures of the East flowed to Europe.
New routes for trading and civilization. They were all open now. The return trip was to prove
very difficult. And unfortunately, many brave sailors were to lose their lives. Yes, it was
triumph. What an accomplishment. 12,000 kilometers, almost 8,000 miles, three
times the distance Columbus traveled with high winds and treacherous currents
both ways. I think you can place a small Portuguese flag on the map. I'm certain
that we can go from here to there by sailing westward. Then you mean that? Yes,
it's possible to sail around the world. There's an original, I must say, young man, eh, what is
your name? Oh, you wouldn't know me, sir. My name is Magellan. Fernando da Magellan.